-We have children the same age
One thing that has been --
I don't know
if you've felt lucky
to have kids too young
to appreciate what's going on.
-Yes.
I'm actually genuinely
grateful for that
just 'cause
I don't know quite how to --
I don't know
what you've done yet.
I don't know if...feeling
there's something wrong here
I'm definitely getting a sense
that my 4-year-old
is starting to suspect
something bad is happening
But I'm managing
to keep that from him,
and he hasn't asked a question
that it seems
he wants the answer to yet
But he's certainly asking about,
"Why can't I see my friends?
-My --
-...extending spring break
at the moment.
"Well, we're still
on spring break,
and spring break may be...
lasting into the early winter.
-My wife is one of those peopl
who just tell children
everything that's going on
-Really?
-She gives it to them straight
Yeah. So now if you come i
and don't wash your hands...
-Yeah.
-...my son will point at you
and scream, "Corona."
-Yes.
-So we have that.
-Okay.
We're doing this differently
-[ Laughs ]
-I have a friend
who has a daughter who's -
he's taught to tell anyone
that she comes into contact with
when they go for a walk
to stay six feet away.
What's been easy with that
is she's always had, um,
a slight [bleep]-off attitud
to strangers
even for a 4-year-old, and now
she is really embracing it
-Oh, that's good.
-She will just yell at peopl
across the road,
"Six feet! Six feet! No! No!
So, the tricky thing is,
how do you unlearn that?
That's the problem.
Or do you just keep it?
-I feel as if "corona" is goin
to be a catch phrase with my son
for a very long time.
Joe Exotic is the
pandemic viewing pleasure
for a lot of people --
"Tiger King."
-Not the hero America needs, but
the hero it deserves right now
-Exactly. You were a
front-runner on this, as well.
You talked about him.
-Don't throw me
into that [bleep].
-You got here early.
You saw something special
in Joe Exotic
when he was a glint
in Netflix's eye.
-That's fair. That's fair.
-So, you talked about he was a
third-party candidate in 2016.
-Yeah.
-I mean, I have to imagine
when he first
came across your plate,
you must have been so delighte
that this was
a real human being.
-Oh, definitely. We just -
We were looking for
kind of the craziest
third-party candidate,
found his ad, and it just --
It was like the lowest-hanging
juiciest fruit,
almost that you think,
"Oh, could this be real?
Mmm! So sweet. So juicy."
Yeah, so, we got in touch
with him around that time
just to check that the story -
or check out that he was
running, yadda, yadda.
And our researcher went back
through his notes and did say,
"Um, no, he's all running.
That's fine.
It seems like
the park he's running
is a little bit dangerous.
We may not want to hold hand
too closely with this.
Plus he started ranting
about a woman named Carole."
Now that seems
such a simpler time.
Such a simpler time!
-[ Laughs ]
-He really got it in for a woman
named Carole. Who knows why?
And it would've been great
if none of us
had ever known why.
Sadly, that's not
the world we live in.
-Sadly. Now, yeah,
we know everything these days.
Nothing goes -- It just turned
out it was like the coronavirus.
It wasn't that there wasn'
a problem with Carole.
There just weren't tests yet
-That's --
-[ Laughs ]
-...have a test to find ou
where her husband is.
-We're going to be --
Stick around.
We're gonna be right back
with more John Oliver.